hello and welcome to the evan carmichael
show i believe in entrepreneurs i want
to see you have success i want to see
you finally get some results from all
the hard work that you're putting into
your business today is a really
important show
some of the topics that we talked about
today could have a permanent and lasting
impact on your business so i would
encourage you to take the next hour grab
a cup of coffee i have my starbucks
frappuccino with me here because we're
going to touch on some really important
topics
on the show today how to get past the
crash with your business how to come up
with a winning business idea how do you
find the right people for your company
and how to demo yourself
getting started
as we build our business
you're gonna get to the point where
you'll get frustrated
i wrote and created a video not too long
ago where
i said starting the business is hard and
it is starting the business is crazy
hard and one guy on youtube wrote back
to say
starting the business is hard how deep
motivational is that
that's crazy
why don't you build me up with something
i wish that somebody told me
how hard it was to start a business when
i got started
because everything looks so easy from
the outside
and i remember
reading books and looking over magazines
and
watching other videos and it all seems
so easy right you come with an idea you
create your product you put it online
you start selling you grow
so easy
and then i started doing it myself and
at the beginning it was all exciting i
had so much momentum i was growing
but nothing was actually really
happening with my business yet
you know i was running off the fumes the
excitement
and then the crash came and i realized
i'm not making enough money to survive
i'm making 300 bucks a month
i don't know what i'm gonna do
and
that was a huge crash for me because i
wasn't expecting it and because it
looked so easy for everybody else i felt
like a humongous failure like how could
these guys all make it huge
and i'm stuck struggling making 300
bucks a month not knowing if i'm gonna
have enough money you know to to go out
for dinner with some friends and i was
too embarrassed and too ashamed to go
and ask for help
everybody gets to that point with their
business everybody goes through
the crash
and if you're prepared for it
if you're expecting it
then it's a lot easier to get through
so starting the business is hard and i
tell people that it's hard and i want
you to think that it's hard
so that when the crash does come when
all the initial excitement and buzz
wears off
you're still willing and ready to keep
going with the company because that's
going to make all the difference in the
world
what helped me
what got me through
was researching
the stories of famous entrepreneurs i
was too embarrassed and ashamed to go
and
ask for help
from my friends and talk about my
business because i was supposed to be
the guy making it
so i looked inward and i started
researching and any famous entrepreneur
story if you look at these guys see how
they got started they all had a crazy
hard time you look at guys like george
lucas who's created star wars or harley
davidson or milton hershey and how they
got started
they had years and years and years of
failure
before they made it
george lucas went six years
of just pure failure and everybody was
telling him
you should go get a job you should take
the safe route
and instead of that
he kept going because he felt like it
was the right thing to do
when he created star
wars he thought it was too wacky for the
general public that nobody would like it
but he kept going
and it became a huge hit that made him a
billionaire
you have to understand that starting a
business is hard it's not meant to
demotivate you
it's meant to build you up
think about
why you're starting this business
whenever you are
in a moment of weakness okay when that
crash comes and you guys you all know
what i'm talking about for people who
have had a business
you know what i'm talking about the
crash hits you
if it's after a week after a month three
months a year whatever it is at some
point the initial buzz and excitement
wears off and you crash
when that happens
take a deep breath
relax
don't do anything crazy
think about why you started this
business
think about what you hope to accomplish
with it
and remember that you are not alone this
is what killed me i thought i was alone
eighty percent of businesses will fail
in five years
you are not the only person going
through this it's okay to share it's
okay to hit that point where you feel
like quitting
i thought about quitting on a regular
basis with my business because i wasn't
making it
i wasn't living the life that i thought
i would have this this wasn't how it was
supposed to work
you know i had a great product i had a
great team
this wasn't the way it was supposed to
go and i remember having to tell my
friends i can't go with you
to dinner
i said i was busy
but really because i couldn't afford it
20 bucks
couldn't afford it
so remember
starting the business is really tough
and when you get to those points where
you think that you're going to crash
dig deep
stay true to who you are remember why
you started this business and look
for stories or people to connect with
that can help you
get through it
i want to get to the questions
so i'm going to answer a question off of
twitter today we've got a question
coming in from
susan who wrote in how do you manage
your time as an entrepreneur
so this is a
a great question and as entrepreneurs we
are time strapped
right you're doing everything yourself
especially in startup mode you're doing
everything you're everything from
the janitor
all the way up to the ceo of your
business
the way i find
that helps me best manage my time
is i break things down into one and a
half hour chunks i try to be really
really focused for an hour and a half
not let myself get too distracted
and i a lot those times across my whole
day
one of the biggest challenges for
entrepreneurs is we're constantly
in reactionary mode right we're
constantly putting out fires
and as a result we don't get to spend
any time really proactively growing our
business i call it ceo time
you want to make sure that you have
ceo time daily
for your business
and this is something
that you can think about where am i
going to spend my time to grow
a lot of entrepreneurs i look at their
schedule it's a it's a mess it's a
nightmare
they're working on something you're
working hard on a project you're in the
flow and then an email comes in
or the phone rings you get distracted
you answer it you put out some fire
you come back to what you're working on
and it's gone
right it takes you 40 minutes to get
back into the state of flow
try to eliminate distractions from your
schedule i try to run a no crisis
business i try to eliminate clients
who are high maintenance
because even if it pays well
all that work
in managing them it just takes up too
much of my day it prevents me from doing
something great with my business
so don't let email overrun your life
don't take unscheduled phone calls
my phone number isn't listed
on my website it's not on my business
card i do business by the phone
but if we're gonna set something up i'm
calling you because i'm always on time
and i don't let people call me and ruin
my day
so block off your day it's an hour and a
half chunks
and make sure when you're spending an
hour and a half on something if it's
your ceo time or if it's a project
you're working on
don't get distracted by something else
i like the 90-minute rule because it
seems to be a great way to be able to
focus your brain after 90 minutes you
can start to get tired
and then your productivity drops off so
i try to be in peak productivity
as much as possible
another great way
susan will put a question from another
great way to manage your time
is to try to chunk things up do anything
that you do
on a weekly basis try to do once a week
anything that you do
on a monthly basis try to do once a
month instead of having it multiple
times in a week do it once a week
instead of doing multiple times during
the day do it once a day
so checking email
if that's a big killer for you
do it once a day segment of time hour
and a half
you're good to go and then the rest your
day
don't worry about your email
for me
every day is segmented into something
else
so for example today's thursday i'm
doing a radio show thursdays are always
my
public facing day
i'll do the radio show i'll do all my
meetings any phone calls i need to take
it's always going to be on a thursday
that sets me up wednesday i'll do my
video
i'll sit down and do
13 14 up to 20 videos
in one day because i'm in the zone and
focused on that
whereas a monday or tuesday i'm doing
more project work
so try to chunk up your time it'll help
you be a lot more productive i know at
the start it's really hard because
there's so many things on your plate
for running the business
doesn't have to be as complicated as you
make it
if you can manage your time properly
welcome back to devon carmichael's show
i believe in helping entrepreneurs i
want to see you have massive success
with your company and that will start
with having a winning business idea now
how do you come up with the winning
business idea i recently met up with an
entrepreneur friend of mine he's been
doing the same thing for about 10 years
and he's bored of his business and wants
to do something else but he doesn't know
what to go into and by the way this is
common this is another truth about
entrepreneurship that nobody talks about
you will get bored of your business
if you don't keep reinventing it
injecting more of yourself into it if
you do the same thing day in and day out
you will get bored
so how do you get a new idea how do you
get ways to improve the company i can
tell you how not to do it
you can't force creativity
i can't say be creative right now give
me the next great business idea right
now when you force yourself to do
something you don't get great results
quick example i'm an investor in a salsa
dancing company we'll teach five to six
thousand people a year how to dance
salsa
and when i started into this company i
was just a student
and if i was looking for a business
opportunity if i said this has to work
right now this has to be my next great
business idea it would have never worked
i'm i'm tall i take big steps i didn't
understand the language i didn't get the
music
i'm learning late in life there's so
many reasons against why this would not
be a great business and if i looked at
it only from a business point of view it
wouldn't have worked but i gave myself
the freedom to explore
and try something new and try something
different that i was interested in
and fell in love with salsa
now at dj events i'm an investor in the
business i'll help teach some classes
it's a ton of fun and it became a
business opportunity
because i gave myself the freedom to
explore and try something else so if
you're looking for a business idea it's
not going to come by forcing
the opportunity you've got to go out
give yourself freedom give yourself time
to get out there try something that
you're interested in even have nothing
to do with business
just like finding somebody on the street
and say i'm going to marry that person
and trying to force love and force
marriage it's not going to happen it's
got to be natural
it's got to flow
so don't stress out if you're trying to
find your business idea and you're
freaking out instruction like i don't
know what to do i don't know what to do
relax chill out a little bit
spend some time
doing something that you want to explore
and discover and if your intention to
start a business something will come
something great will come and it's going
to be out of a passion and pure love
that's the way to get your winning
business idea
i want to get to the calls i have
stephanie on the line stephanie where
are you from and how can i help um yes i
am from dallas texas and i have a little
small business that i'm trying to start
pink magic
um it's going to be a clothing store um
mostly for
females but i do want to branch out
eventually and do males clothing as well
okay and i just want to know how um how
i should go about kind of getting
everything started because i'm new to
the whole idea of a business
why do you want to start this company
stephanie i want to help
women who
don't necessarily have like a big budget
to shop on i want to help people be able
to look pretty on a budget
okay is that is that your story do you
have a a painful moment that you
remember trying to find these kinds of
clothes to yourself um i do whenever i
was younger i grew up poor like i didn't
grow up with the best of clothes i
didn't get to have like new clothes
every year like everyone else
so as i grew older i kind of wanted to
um help
children or young adults coming into
teens and i just want to help people so
pretty because i know whenever i was
younger i didn't always feel pretty i
didn't feel pretty until i was about
17 and i moved away from home so i just
want people to know you know it is okay
that you can't afford like the things
that
some people may have
definitely this is fantastic
most people who call in
they started a business with no real
purpose but you're starting this for
real reason and you can really tie your
story into it so i would strongly
encourage you to use your story at the
front of everything
okay
now in terms of actually taking the next
steps what were you thinking of doing
did you want to open up your own store
from scratch or
what was your plan next step
um i i believe that online marketing
online is really um a key point right
now i i think that i should do an online
store first and then eventually branch
out and
get maybe a location in dallas and then
hopefully it'll grow big and people will
like my story and i can go la and new
york
big dreams big dreams it's good so
what's what's holding you back from
starting your website
um money
i'm actually currently looking for an
investor or maybe like a small business
model to kind of get my
business on the road
so starting up and going after capital
can be
a full-time job what what i would try to
do
because all you really need is a
developer to help you out right
yes that's correct i would try to find a
developer who
believes in what you're doing
and can come on board to help you out
with this and maybe they become
a partner in the business
or they invest some of their time
and in return they get
if you can't afford to pay them right
now they get some shares in the business
or they get some future consideration
with the business
and this would be great if you can find
uh a woman
web developer because there aren't as
many of them as there are guys and
people who really believe in what you're
all about is there anybody that comes to
mind that you can connect with
um there isn't actually i i don't have a
lot of connections right now i'm still
wanting to um get connections into
people that have businesses and i really
don't though i don't have anyone
what about starting through
an existing network like facebook
yes i have thought of that as well
you have zero development costs because
it's already been up right the site's
already built
and it lets you get your message out in
a really social way
okay yeah i can i can see that
can you do that today okay um i just got
my business actually um through the
through the county so i just now um
bought the name and everything so
definitely i would i could um start a
facebook page definitely
start a facebook page today
and let me know the results you can
always email me or if you want to call
back i'm on every two weeks and i want
to hear about your success
okay absolutely okay good luck
thank you
and for everybody
you're just trying to get started
don't let
the lack of money hold you back she
didn't have a web developer that doesn't
mean you can't start your company
you want to start small you want to
start with what you have and start
building something right start getting
some momentum
into your business and a great way to do
it if you don't have a budget and you
don't have any technical skills
is use something like facebook
a lot of the tools are already built in
there for you and when you're ready to
expand
because you've made some sales and you
can show that it works
then you have money coming in
so stop spending money and try to find
ways to go out and make money using the
tools and knowledge that you already
have
welcome back to the evan carmichael show
i believe in entrepreneurs i wanted to
build a great company and have a massive
impact in this world
and one of the great ways to do it is to
build a team
it's hard to do everything yourself and
you can't if you want to build something
significant you need people around you i
got a question from one of my youtube
viewers wrote and say how do you find
the right people
and
if i wanted somebody and they said no
but they want to come back in after i've
had success should i let them back in or
not
let's start with the first part
most entrepreneurs
their first employee
really works out if you look at the
success of companies you look at who the
original team was and who the first
employee was they're rarely still there
down the line
and a lot of that is your fault as the
entrepreneur and i i mean i did this too
the first guy i hired
wasn't is not a part of my business
anymore now
the key thing here
is
you have to stand for something as a
business
you have to have values that attract
people to your business
90 of america they wake up and they
drive to a job that they hate people are
yearning to belong to something that is
meaningful
and so
that has to come out
with your business
and it starts with you understanding
what is the change that you want to have
in the world
our last caller was talking about
how she grew up poor and how she
couldn't afford
nice clothing and she had to figure out
a way to feel pretty while still on a
budget
now she doesn't just sell clothes
she's telling my feelings
and people
will associate with that
and want to be a part of that
you have to think for your own business
what do you stand for because you're not
just selling clothes you're not just
selling tables you're not just selling
lawn maintenance
you have to stand for something more
than that
and when you do it's not only going to
just inspire you
but it's going to inspire the right
people to come and join your business
so when you're looking for somebody new
to join you it's not just do they have
the skills that you need it's not just
do they have the right personality
that's going to fit with you it's do
they believe in the same values that you
do do they love what you stand for
so my advice to the last caller if
you're if you're trying to find a
website developer don't just
jump ship with any website developer
who's out there
you want somebody who feels the same way
you want somebody who grew up poor who
grew up feeling like they weren't pretty
and really believed in what you're
trying to do because they're gonna not
just give you their mind they're gonna
give you your heart and their soul
so when you're thinking about bringing
new people on
that has to be the start
it has to be where you begin what do you
stand for what makes you different and
how can you inspire people i want to get
to the calls i have katie on the line
katie where are you from and how can i
help i'm in oklahoma city
and i am a pageant consultant and i'm in
the hotbed of pageants down here in the
southwest all right
and i wonder
i have well i'm in the hot bed a pageant
you know i am a pretty specific niche
and so i wonder
i want to cast a broad net to not only
get girls that are already in pageants
but i want to cast a broad net so i can
get the girls that are considering
getting into pageants because in my neck
of the woods it's like athletics for
girls you know same commitment same
money spent that sort of thing
as it would be if they were boys in
football and so i want to cast a broad
net do i put up a billboard because they
got those digital billboards now do i
put an ad in the paper what do you
suggest is going to be my best place for
me to hit the families and girls that
i'm trying to find
why did you start this business were you
in the pageant were you yourself in a
pageant
yeah yourself before yes and now you
help girls what age do they start with
you
uh well we do the miss teen pageants so
we start out at like 14 in the training
and coaching and then they get into the
miss teen pageants and hopefully have
enough success and confidence to go into
the you know the bigger state um
national pageants like the miss america
miss usa is there somebody who coaches
done really really well um well we're a
new we're a new little business i mean
we've only been in business for like six
months i've i've been in the industry
many years and my partner has been in
the industry many years and she's a
former miss colorado okay so we we have
uh credentials behind us would you
consider yourself an expert at what you
do absolutely yes i hope so i like the
confidence
so listen there are a couple ways to
promote this
and
i've always preferred not spending money
until i'm making money and if possible i
mean you're just six months in you're
still getting your your sea legs with
this company i'd hate for you to go out
and spend a whole bunch of money on a
billboard advertising that doesn't work
right i'm assuming you don't have
massive budgets to go out there and buy
up every billboard in the city no we
don't have massive budgets but we do
have a small amount of cash flow and we
wanted to reinvest it into the company
somehow without it just sitting
so think about if you read a magazine
are you reading the stories or are you
reading the ads
well actually i'm for me i'm probably
reading the ads
that's not the experience of most people
you don't buy a magazine to read the ads
well i buy fashion magazines that's
primarily ads so no but i follow what
you're saying
so if you're on the other side now right
if you're the business owner it's much
better for you to be in there creating
the stories to have stories written
about you for you to be sharing your
expertise than for you to be out there
buying that
oh
talk about change direction
does that make sense that makes absolute
sense that makes absolute sense and i'm
embarrassed to say that one of the
classes that i teach my little gals of
course now we're in oklahoma and i'm not
you know
um
rupert murdoch but one of the classes i
teach the little girls is self-promotion
and media mastery what the heck am i
thinking
hey that's okay
now you're on the same page
and that's priceless you are so smart
that's and that's free i can write press
releases all day long
and i'd love to see you have a regular
column you know in whatever the oklahoma
newspaper is
oh yeah that'd be real we could do that
in the smaller towns because we get a
lot of draw from the smaller towns and
they could probably use the content
that's great and now you're casting a
wide net and people are going to be
reading those stories
and and you can talk
not just about the success you've had
and how to be great uh as a as a pageant
but you're trying to get the people who
are thinking about what where do i want
to send my child
right like what's what's the best thing
for them to get involved in if it's not
athletics what it is so
you have to kind of step out step up a
little bit and not only focus on how to
be successful in the pageant business
but why this is an important business to
get into for girls
absolutely well it is because it offers
so much as far as scholarships and
education and when they have to have a
platform they have to develop something
relevant for them to have a message
about and it's you know all of that goes
towards college admissions i mean
everything
it's great
and right i don't want to say you know
you don't you can still do the billboard
you can still do the advertising the
great thing about that is you want to be
able to track
success
so everything's measurable right if you
have a billboard if somebody calls you
up
they can say you know you ask them how
did you find me no i saw your billboard
so advertising can work but measure and
see
see if it's going to generate results
for you if it does you expand but
typically especially for startups you
get way more leverage out of being that
expert and sharing your opinions and
these are things like you are you're not
just starting this business just to try
to make some money you you are an expert
you're changing people's lives you
passionately believe in what you're
doing and if you let that come out
people are going to flock to you
perfect and it's free
magic word for entrepreneurs right
well i am going to just go and jump up
and down you have saw i mean you have
opened up my whole day for me
all right i'm glad i could help katie
good luck thanks so much and i'll be
listening so i'm on every two weeks if
you want to call back with an update i'd
love to hear how you're doing absolutely
okay thanks katie thank you bye
so for everybody listening
listen one of the biggest problems is
marketing your business right how do you
get the word out we have great products
and services but if people don't know
about it
how are they going to come and buy from
you
you can think about advertising and
again if you're going to do it make sure
you test everything small scale see if
it works and if so expand but you should
be an expert in your industry you should
be the best at what you do you should be
master class
and so if you are you have to share that
expertise you got to let people know you
exist and every
story that comes out
every story that a reporter is writing
something on they need an expert
you could be that expert whenever
somebody's talking about your industry
you should be the person quoted all it
takes is reach out to reporters
letting them know your expertise
getting to know them a little bit and if
you can be a great resource for them
they're going to keep coming back to you
because you're making their lives easier
you're not just selling them you're
making their daily life easier because
these reporters are not experts at what
they do they're actually writing but
they're not experts on your field and
they need your help
so start on a budget and promote
yourself as an expert welcome back to
the evan carmichael show i want to see
you drive massive sales to your business
and a great way to do it is to have a
powerful demo
you need to be able to show people not
only what you do but to make them feel
it
you can explain what you do and it hits
the monological level but you have to be
able to solve their pain solve their
problem and make them feel it in a way
that connects with them
if you can do that they're much more
likely to buy from you
one of my favorite stores here is an
entrepreneur named richard davis he
created the first all kevlar bulletproof
vest
and when he was out trying to sell this
he had a hard time at the beginning he
wanted to go out and reach out to police
stations as police officers hey they
need bulletproof vests and he called
them up and they said hey you're crazy
you don't have a bulletproof vest you
know how how much force comes out of a
gun
a vest can't stop that bullet
and he didn't get anywhere
so we switch things around and he called
the police station set up a time he went
in
to see them
put on his vest pulled out a gun and
shot himself in the chest
now luckily it worked or that would be
the end of the
story but it was a powerful demo the man
literally stood behind this product
and it showed them
how it could actually work because
people are bombarded with sales messages
all the time
right you are hit constantly with people
trying to pitch you something
but nobody does a really good job a very
few companies do a great job
of clearly showing it off having a
powerful demo
do you want to try to move people
from just explaining what it is that you
do
to showing them what it is that you do
and having them feel it put it in their
hand make them
have a little bit of a taste of the
great feeling they're gonna get by
working with your business if you can do
that
then sales will come in
once richard davis started going out and
demo in his product they started
ordering because they believed it they
saw how it could work
they may have thought hey this guy's a
little bit crazy
but he obviously believes in his product
and he can show off that it works
so find ways with your business to have
a powerful demo to make people feel what
your business is all about
i want to get to the calls i have
clarisse on the phone clarisse did i
pronounce your name properly
yes clary
clarice all right where are you from and
how can i help
i'm from pittsburgh pennsylvania all
right welcome
thank you
um so i've even invented a few things
but today i want to talk to you about um
my fragrance my perfume that i came up
with okay
now um my question is do you feel that
the market is already too saturated with
so many fragrances like that there's
really not a chance for another good
fragrance
um to be out
the market is never saturated for a
great product
okay there's always room at the top
if you look at any
business
there's full of competition any business
right there's tons of competition
but almost nobody's doing it really
really well and there's a niche that you
can work out what is what is special
about your fragrance
well what's special about my fragrance
is it's
not so overpowering
that it smells really really sweet soft
and fresh
it covers up cigarette smoke
it smells like
fresh flowers it's different because
it's a unique smell
that anybody that i've ever you know
sold it to or let try or smell it there
they fall in love with it instantly
it's just a unique soft
soft and powerful smell you don't have
to use a lot of it you can use a small
amount of it it'll last um the whole day
almost these are all great points now
is the fear
of it being too saturated market holding
you back from doing something with it
yes
and um what i've been thinking i've been
watching like a bunch of different uh
perfume commercials and i've been trying
to put up i'm trying to piece put
together a good commercial for it
and i'm just looking for great tips and
pointers but
that being a factor of everything it
does kind of hold me back like i'm
afraid to
fail i guess
yeah
but and that's a that's a real fear
right it's not it's not just some joke
you know fear of feeling is a huge thing
that holds people back
is your plan to make this commercial and
then put it on tv is that what you're
trying to do with it
well i'm going to start it out um with
the uh social media and i want to ask
you about that too i want to start it
out like with the youtube and um you
know the different facebooks and
linkedin linkedin
teach all of the you know the the social
media outlets who uh let you upload
videos okay
i want you to write this company down
jones soda have you ever heard of jones
no i i don't believe that i've had okay
i want you to look them up joan soda
this is so relevant for you because
you're going up against huge companies
right you're going up against some of
the biggest companies in the world you
cannot compete
by putting out one commercial
you can't play their game
joan soda
they make they make all sorts of
different
pop flavors coke flavors you know that
that kind of stuff uh root beer all
sorts of different pop flavors
they go up against some of the biggest
companies in the world too
coke pepsi etc
and they do it in a different way and
this is going to be your challenges how
can you stand out and be different and
not go up against a huge competition on
their terms because just taking out a
commercial
is not going to be a huge success factor
for you because everybody else is doing
it and they're doing it better than you
right i think right like chanel has
great commercial
yes exactly
and hope to have the same team and
produce a chanel quality commercial
so don't try to be you know a c great
product of them be an a of yourself and
do something unique and different that
will help spread the buzz for you
okay that is so wild that you said that
because those commercials are like the
ones i hone in on like i try to research
them i watch them over and over again
and um
yeah so you don't
think that the social media advertising
is like one of the better ways to go
with this
you can i definitely want you to use
social media
i definitely want you to leverage that
because it's so powerful and so cheap
cost-effective but
i don't want you to go the route of just
trying to be a chanel junior
okay yeah you've got to find a different
way to stand out and be unique
i've gotta run as we're kind of at the
end of the program but like call back in
if you have questions i'm on every two
weeks i'd love to hear about your
progress
okay thank you so much for having me no
problem good luck and for everybody
listening
model success
so find companies who've done what
you're trying to do and copy what's
worked for them make it to work for your
business
she's going up against huge competitors
you'll find somebody who's done the same
thing find that rebel brand who stood
out for for her jones thought it would
be a great company to model thank you
everybody
i had so much fun the hour always goes
by so quickly thank you so much to my
producers fernanda and steve i'm on
every two weeks i look forward to
hearing from you in two weeks time and
in the meantime you can check out my
website everyone.com
i'll find everybody believe and i'll see
you soon